si le gouvernement n'est pas responsable
du virus il est responsable du choix de
ne pas des confiner la culture une
phrase signée des professionnels du
spectacle en colère de ne pas pouvoir
exercer au delà ils réclament un plan
massif pour les salaires manifestation
aujourd'hui dans les rues de tours 250
personnes se sont rassemblées
manon vanoverbeke la joie apparente des
presque 300 manifestants ne doit pas
cacher leur désarroi actuel
depuis la fin du mois d'octobre les
artistes intermittents du spectacle sont
privés de représentation
ils peuvent répéter préparer spectacles
concerts et chorégraphies mais ça ne
leur rapporte aucune rémunération
c'est une de leurs revendications s'il
n'y a pas cette aide massive pour les
salaires c'est tout le système qui
s'effondre
ça sert à rien d'ailleurs d'avoir après
des années qu spécifique à l'assurance
chômage pour les artistes que tu sois
sont les artistes n'auront plus droit
puisqu'ils n'auront pas assez travaillé
donc de toutes façons c'était pour les
salaires est fondamentale et surtout
c'est que madame bachelot nous dit vous
pouvez répéter vous pouvez travailler
oui mais avec quel argent l'autre grande
demande des manifestants
c'est la prolongation d'un an de l'année
blanche elle permettrait aux
intermittents d'être indemnisé jusqu'au
31 août 2022 avec la fermeture des lieux
culturels
beaucoup se retrouvent sans travail
isolé voir obligé de se reconvertir en
étant là tous ensemble c'est aussi
soutenir un peu le moral des troupes
puisque là le moral est très bas et
faire très attention ça aussi à ça parce
que faut pas qu'on se soutienne faut
qu'on soit là les uns pour les autres
pour contacter les gens tombent dans des
dépressions
mais pour pouvoir travailler et donc se
produire sur scène
certains manifestants réclament
simplement la réouverture des lieux
culturels